[Musique]
qui comprend ce qu'on nous propose comme
réforme des retraites qui comprend on
découvre subitement qu'il ya un sujet
enseignants on découvre subitement qu'il
ya des sujets parallèle qui sont
extrêmement attendre personne n'y
comprend rien pour nous c'est clair
c'est un recul c'est un renoncement
j'ai envie de dire tout ça pour ça
tout ça pour ça emmanuel macron n'est
pas un président qui réforme c'est un
président qui fracture qui divise la
société française c'est qu'avec emmanuel
macron vous aurez davantage de résumer
régimes spéciaux à la fin de son mandat
qu'avant son mandat il y a pas d'unité
il n'y a pas de garantie financière rien
de rien se voyait quelqu'un de bien je
le dresseur logique même si malade en
l'air selon ce projet gouvernemental est
amphigourique environ l'unc et là je
sens un nuage dans ce studio cela veut
dire que c'est un projet en ré était
embrouillée obscures il utilise cette
réforme va être faussement universel
cette réforme sera vraiment injuste
c'est une réforme c'est une non réformes
dans le gouvernement s'est mis lui même
dans une situation infernale et et moir
honnêtement je ne le souhaite pas je
souhaite qu'il ya une réforme des
retraites je souhaite qu'elle soit
efficace qu'elle soit plus juste par
principe que nous disons nous
aujourd'hui c'est qu'il faut d'abord
préserver le niveau de pension des
retraites et pour ça il vaut mieux
repousser l'âge légal en fonction de
l'espérance de vie en bonne santé
plutôt que finalement joué sur les
pensions ou alors pire encore augmenter
les cotisations qui revient à une
augmentation des impôts dès que vous
nous mettrons bientôt sur la table avec
les républicains une proposition très
novatrice sur la pénibilité c'est à dire
que pour tous les métiers pénibles
reconnues par la médecine du travail
tous les cinq ans une année de
bonification parce que les métiers
pénibles les carrières hachées les
carrières dur les carrières longues
doivent être récompensés
la seule réforme des retraites possible
sur le temps long c'est une réforme
fondée sur la justice sociale
l' inverse du président la république
mais depuis le début de la crise quelle
autre partie a posé sur la table une
proposition nouvelle
quelle autre ok nous sommes les premiers
à le faire avec le régime universel de
pénibilité
[Musique]